[Applaudissements]
alors attention je vous le dis il ya
cinq fils un seul empêche réellement
maxime de tombé dans la potion magique
qu'elle y voit là c'est vous qui allez
couper les fils alors on va jouer avec
des questions d'actu avec vous unissez
vous avec tout le monde
première question sur ses news
jean lassalle a eu un comportement
curieux lequel il a bu un verre de vin
chaud pendant l'interview il a
déstabilisé la journaliste il a fait
tournoyer un gilet jaune au dessus de la
tête où il a pété deux fois en
s'excusant d'avoir mangé du souffleur
tapis c'est là des dons doivent alléger
les jaunes
j'ai mal alors c'est faux l'habitabilité
la journaliste a mis en garde la drague
et elle était capable tout aussi
légitime évidemment que tous ici sur les
hautes dunes humaniste et une résistance
j'ai perdu le fil de ses souvenirs la
bronca qu'on adore est exceptionnel bon
ça va donc il ya un peu gras gay la
journaliste jean lassalle vous pouvez
couper un fil kelly il y voit là pour
écouter rapide on va voir s'il va tomber
merci ça va maxime c'est bon comme aller
au niveau du coupage le fil c'est bon
non qu'est-il arrivé à marie-christine
la championne du jeu tout le monde veut
prendre sa place
elle s'est fait éliminer elle a dépassé
les elle a dépassé les 200 mille euros
de gains l affronter un de ses ex où
elle a eu la gastro je pense qu'elle est
elle a dû dépasser les 200 mille euros
illuminé exactement après 213 victoire
un gain total de 196 1900 euros se
calmer vous avec les ciseaux marie
christine a perdu à tout le monde veut
prendre sa place
regardez les défauts l'hôtel dieu je
patrouille et l'on sait la pitié
salpêtrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre 1200 euros 3900 5000 et vous
partez au 1800 et vont assez sans jamais
être sûr d'atteindre les 100 bio
connaissez-vous pierre hitier je prends
le fauteuil 200 mille euros devient
alors si vous feriez si vous gagnez 200
millions comme ça tout de suite
ces principes ou moi je rembourserai
crédit de ma maison tout de suite et un
put de loyer je suis content d'accord
bas très bas il en reste 20 ans non non
on n'a pas on n'est pas là mais on
n'achète pas la burqa mais qui n'a pris
paul bonhomme vert il est en train de me
parler de ces et dans les îles alors moi
je vous invite à papeete pour qu'on
prenne un air tahiti ensemble ça a l'air
très sympathique ce vol lui je me
demande si vous n'êtes pas mieux comme
ça cela plus vite au niveau duquel vous
faites quoi vous à moi je crée une
entreprise aux jambes aux des gens qui
n'ont pas l'emploi voilà où les coupes
et kelly attention à décider de la forme
c'est moi qui décide de tout à bas les
îles il est choisi je sais pas on est
vers la fin du jeu là ou pas on va dire
violet hockey
alors marie-christine je vous le dis
elle s'était elle à elle c'était clashé
avec le maître de midi christian quesada
qui avait remporté 8 109 mille euros il
s'était un peu clasher sur twitter pour
ensuite passer sur mon compte privé nous
avons le tweet scoop en additionnant
quatre fois s'étend sur 100 m usain bolt
bat le record du monde du 400 m bah
voilà championne mais euh comment dire
c'est christian academy ça parce qu'il
disait que c'était lui le plus grand
gagnant de tous les temps et on voit là
il reproche à marie christine d'avoir
acheté sa place plusieurs fois dans le
jeu en proposant des sommes allant de
3200 à 16000 euros
c'est l'énigme assez le jeu qu'elle a
dit marie-christine ce sont les règles
du jeu quand je joue à un jeu de société
je ne vais pas dire à ce serait mieux si
les règles étaient différents les règles
sont ce qu'elles sont aux joueurs avec
et si ça ne plaît pas on ne joue pas ça
fait surtout en ces temps de jeu les
jaune où les gens c'est ça mais c'est
grave ici la page est tournée
ouais et on attend la parole du
président de la république succès il
faut vraiment je vous dis que le
président de la république
voilà parle de ça j'étais au lycée avec
lui non non c'est ok c'est là qu'elle
était dans ma classe
c'est quoi ces gens non je t'assure
question que chaque classe il était
demain au lycée descartes à anthony on
était ensemble travaille bien il était
c'est un gars un peu étrange comme
maintenant mais très intelligent très
sympa il était un peu à part c'est ouf
c'était ton pote toujours voiture et il
m'a rien reverser
[Rires]
question l événement très attendu a eu
lieu le week-end dernier à new york
la circoncision du chien de barack obama
inauguration du musée virtuel du sexe la
présentation de la première enceinte
muette désigné par kelly v de v line la
peau et ou bien le défilé victoria's
secret et l'ariège quoi pense à la baie
il faut que la d il ya eu les effets
victoria si je veux voir les images
d'avant on a les images
alors sachez que toutes les personnes
que vous allez voir ne sont pas mon
délire il a réuni pas moins de soixante
mannequins comme qu'elle émérite il y
avait mis à l'eau il y avait cindy bruno
que j'embrasse voilà et non mais c'est
vrai mais sorti avec nom et benjamin est
un gros mytho
[Rires]
c'est l'événement était très attendue
aux états unis il y avait même mon amie
rita aura que j'embrasse voilà et elle
était là-bas rytas tu veux en venir nous
voir c'est con tu veux bien non on était
venu noah et c'est vrai qu'elle est quel
visage beaucoup apprécié quand elle est
alors ce plateau ce soir je veux pas
faire le mytho comme cela dit c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que voilà après qui fait
que c'est très riche non c'est pas elle
a compris alors bien évidemment on a les
images c'est une bonne réponse d'elie
semoun ou regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
série 6000 attendait là y'a un moment
soit la série fait même pas regardé
était là dans cette vidéo qui vient de
passer
oui oh oui absolument sublime un bon
verre contient pas les unes que les
autres
ne me dites pas qu elle il n'y a pas une
jeune femme qui vous a un tout petit peu
et mousty c'est normal il est marié ça
le regarde quand même quoi qu'il ait
trouvé belle qu'on aime alors merrill
qui se fout à poil dans ton dos auquel
il coupait un pull les cadors ont versé
à khar yalla coupé merci merci
quelle joie quelle joie que vous suivez
bien le jeu interrogé sur ces techniques
de drague sur rtl be clos du groupe big
flo et oli a déclaré oui je suis oui je
suis le plus de rigueur même si je suis
le plus moche des deux géants zizi qui
n'a jamais servi
j'ai toujours refusé les avances
d'isabelle morini-bosc où j'ai toujours
eu peur des filles micflow aïoli qu'on
embrasse et les deux frérots qui doivent
nous regarder en face il reste que
selanne l'adena records des filles non
ça ne m'a dit je sais le plus moche
regardez c'était chez stéphane bern
l'ami de gilles verdez non à la bonne
heure ils se sont confiés by chloé 10
sur leur amour et big flo est le plus
grand dragueur je sais que les fans
aussi et elle l aime bien bicloo elle
allait bien mais il faut regarder lequel
il fut ce dragueur alors là je réponds
en direct effectivement je suis le plus
de rigueur même si je suis le plus moche
d2 ça peut venir
mais on compense avec du charisme de
charme des trophées des buts et c'est
regarder quand la beauté c'est le succès
subjectif mais pas tant alors vous ne
coupez pas si beaucoup c'est qu'il faut
suivre circoncise et sa lisible
attention attention si nous tombons pas
c'est gagné pour est dit là bas comment
vous êtes au niveau du coupage
c'est bon c'est bon attention dernière
question voilà qu'elle eut là explique
être vexé de ne pas avoir été invité
dans burger quiz
jean marie le pen elie semoun jean marie
bigard ou gad elmaleh à votre avis c'est
qu'ils améliorent le chef sait qui c'est
christine elie semoun l'abbé elie semoun
la baisse que c'est vrai ils disent que
c'est bon c'est la vérité un gant va
regarder l'extrait
bientôt elle a les boules parce qu'ils
m'ont pas invité le burger quiz alors
que j'aime chez ce premier écueil étant
d'être fait pas partie concurrente
celle qui était avec nous c'est et
florence foresti en plus dans mon équipe
qui m'a plus être dans mon équipe mais
je comprends pas pourquoi ils m'ont pas
invité j'étais un peu vexé je me suis
dit merde c'est vrai qu'elle est non
mais c'est vrai vous êtes excellent
devrait bien faire en plus cette
émission mais devrait coûter bammer mais
la hiace jérôme commandeur qui va
présenter un petit peu gérard darmon
quoi il va vous invite avec peut-être qu
alain chabat est antisémite je sais pas
[Rires]
non non c'est pas en tout cas c'est pas
grave
non mais c'est pas allez vous remettre
en fiche parce que c'est pas parce qu'il
a fait trois fois au moins un tp mp avec
une bonne ambiance
sauf que c'est pas ça la raison as tu
crois bah je vois pas tellement d'eau
puisque vous en ai trouvé beaucoup
d'humoristes son émission qui sont dans
dans des gens sont ils en sont pas là
quand même il ya moi je n'en ai pas
d'autres et non il est très populaire et
drôle et plus haut il l'a fait les
premières pourquoi le pourvoi
sincèrement c'est pas grave
ben franchement je ne suis pas la strada
tout va bien en tout cas il y avait
sauvé macquinghen
[Applaudissements]
il a gagné le micro-trottoir d'andré il
va faire ce que vous adorez quand ils
posent des questions et après pose une
autre question allait couper quand même
aller elle a craqué sa robe
c'est fait sk l'un de ses fils ça
m'étonne de l'autre côté
[Applaudissements]